l'egypte et la grèce sont désormais
autorisés à tirer chacune le maximum
davantage des ressources disponibles
dans la zone économique exclusive
notamment des réserves de pétrole et de
gaz un traité signé en réponse à
l'accord conclu entre la turquie et la
libye fin 2019
cette entente turco-libyenne autorisant
car à accéder à une large zone en
méditerranée orientale où d'importants
gisements d'hydrocarbures ont été
découverts ces dernières années il faut
dire que l'enjeu est de taille pour la
grèce et la turquie en méditerranée
orientale le bassin levantin qui s'étend
de la crète et de l'île de rodez à
l'ouest jusqu'aux côtes asiatiques à
l'est recèle 5765 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz estimations de la
commission géologique américaine
réalisée en 2010 ankara mène depuis
plusieurs mois des recherches en
hydrocarbures dans cette zone disputée
le 10 août dernier le déploiement d'un
navire de recherches sismiques turc et
de son escorte militaire au sud de l'île
grecque de kastellorizo a été vécu par
la grèce comme la provocation de trop et
à déclencher une escalade des tensions
après plusieurs semaines de bras de fer
en mer méditerranée orientale athènes et
ankara ont multiplié les manoeuvres
militaires ces derniers jours la turquie
a fait savoir ce jeudi qu'elle
procéderait à des exercices militaires
incluant des exercices de tir les 1er et
2 septembre prochain au large de ses
côtes au nord-est de chypre en face
chypre justement la grèce la france et
l'italie font front commun en
méditerranée orientale dans le cadre
d'une initiative de coopération des
navires américains sont également
présents dans le cadre des missions de
l'otan
mais les états unis ne semblent pas
vouloir prendre parti jusqu'à présent la
méditerranée n'avait en tout cas pas
connu une telle présence militaire
depuis de nombreuses années la guerre
ouverte est encore loin mais la montée
des tensions entre athènes et ankara se
poursuit bel et bien